Chris Tucker is in this movie silver
linings playbook is directed by David
O'Russell a very good filmmaker at
Starr's Bradley Cooper Robert DeNiro
Jennifer Lawrence and Chris Tucker which
was a big surprise to me and I was
really happy to see him in a movie that
wasn't rush hour it's about this guy
Bradley Cooper now he has bipolar and
man does he have bipolar he has got it
Wow movie starts out with him being
discharged from a mental institution so
right off the bat we know there ain't
something entirely right with this guy
I'm not gonna tell you why he was there
but he did have a breakdown of sorts
obviously he goes and he lives again
with his family Robert De Niro and his
wife now these guys are obviously are
they're on edge they're worried because
they don't know what this guy's gonna do
he could go to bed with one thing on his
mind wake up with a completely different
mindset 100% he says whatever comes to
his mind immediately like he just he
can't turn it off he has like advanced
Tourette's he runs into Jennifer
Lawrence and she is also a very troubled
young woman and they bond over the fact
that they're both just so they're weird
and it's such a beautiful movie I love
this movie it was so well acted and
beautiful it's just a beautiful looking
movie it looks so good
there's such a unique visual style that
David O'Russell gave this movie if he
saw the fighter another one of his films
he has this really different way of
filming movies where he puts shots in a
film that you normally would think okay
so this is a really intense moment right
like he's zooming in close to the actor
now he's panning away really close from
the actor like what's going on here he
found the right tone for this movie and
he rode with it this is one of the best
directed films I've seen all year
Bradley Cooper in this movie see it's
weird for me because I've already seen
the place beyond the pines at TIFF that
officially was just announced to come
out next March look forward to that
because I think he gives an oscar-worthy
performance in that movie but here he is
just as good this man is really doing
well I'm so excited that Bradley Cooper
is given good performances and movies
because he's just he's so good here with
this in place beyond the pines he has
sold me this guy can act and he is just
perfect in this movie for this role
Bradley Cooper and Jennifer Lawrence
have some of the best chemistry I've
seen all year so far they're so good
together in this movie and these
characters they seem some
feel they just they feel like real
people they have real problems they say
things you're like yes I understand that
and even though these people are so
over-the-top strange like they just say
stuff really Wow and I can't really
relate to that you do you just you're
late to these people because there's
something in them that you feel like yes
I felt that way sometimes this is one of
the few times this year where I've
actually forgotten that I was watching a
movie at times that is the highest level
of praise I can give to a movie is to
say that I actually forgot that I was
watching a piece of fiction there were
moments in this film that I was so
sucked into these characters I was so
into these moments I just I wanted so
much to just watch this movie and I
almost didn't want it to end that it was
amazing to me how I actually started to
forget at times that this is a movie let
me also talk a little bit about Robert
DeNiro okay there's no more praise I can
give DeNiro he's an amazing actor I've
loved him my entire life he's one of my
favorite actors even though he's had a
string of not-so-great movies lately
I've never seen him be bad in the movie
nevertheless is the best he's been in
years I honestly think he is
oscar-worthy in this movie I am so happy
to see Robert De Niro back in a great
movie because it just I've been missing
that lately
DeNiro man he is gold in this movie all
the performances are great Jennifer
Lawrence is on fire in this film
gratefully she had this after house at
the end of the street because the wow
just she is great here once again she is
able to wash away the garbage that was
the chemistry between these actors the
fantastic dialogue the interesting story
great direction I love this movie it is
a beautiful piece of art it means
something it makes you think it's funny
it's heartfelt you just you really get
into these characters and the story and
that's what's most important is when you
really care about the people portrayed
in this film and like I said I actually
forgot at times I was watching a movie
that's why silver linings playbook gets
an A+
thanks a lot for watching guys for sure
do not miss this movie when it comes out
it's a very special film don't miss it
and as always if you liked this review
then you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes